sur la place du village de saintou un
drôle de camion attire le regard la
ruralinette c'est son nom ne vend rien
mais ceux qui la connaissent ne peuvent
plus s'en passer comme Josette une
habituée super merci je suis venue parce
qu'il réclame une taxe fonière alors que
la maison elle est
insalubre N et sont les occupant à temps
complet de ce camping-car qui sillonne
les routes de l'Indre on va le
mettreattestation va le mettre les
photos et puis je vais faire un petit
écrit je vous
sortirai la copie de ce que j'écrit
comme ça vous pourrez mettre dans vos
dossier mission accompli le document a
bien été transmis au service des impôts
une opération banale sauf pour les 100
millions de Français touchés par
l'îrisme
électronique j'ai internet mais comme je
sais pas pas m'
servir donc je viens je sais pas m'
servir et puis je ne veux pas m'en
servir voilà la ruralinette fait partie
de la centaine de bureaux itinérants
labellisé France service pour venir en
aide aux administrés en galère les gens
de primabord vont être assez réticents
puis après dans la dans la discussion on
les détend un petit peu et puis là il
s'ouvre et puis nous raconte beaucoup
plus puis démarche on en arrive à 10
parce que au final on traite plein
d'opérateurs et des fois on garde des
personnes 2 he et ilessortent ils sont
content et ça c'est c'est bien ça le
redonne un petit peu confiance en
l'administration alors ce petit marché à
ce matine ONJ de
personnes bien aujourd'hui la
ruralinette reçoit la visite des
responsables de l'association famille
rurale de l'Indre qui a financé le
dispositif avec des aides publiques
oublé ça pour pas oubl nous ça fait 70
ans qu'elle existe l'association à
saintou et on a commencé ils ont
commencé à à fournir des machines à lver
aux gens parce que c un besoin
aujourd'hui ben voilà les machines à
Laever sont un peu transformé et ça
devent la rualinette et j'ai souvent
tendance à dire que la ru ralinette
c'est un petit peu les écrivains publics
en fin de compte c'est aujourd'hui enfin
dans le temps les gens savaient pas
écrire donc il allent voir les écrivins
publics et puis aujourd'hui et bien on a
a besoin d'utiliser l'informatique et
donc l'informatique vient à N je vous
laisse notre petit fer ok merci les
jours de marché nie est aussi
ambassadrice du projet si vous avez
besoin quand vous venez sur le marché de
démarch démarch je vous laisse un petit
document qui vous permet de venir nous
rencontrer entenduoup bonne journée
journ pas bne je vais en avoir une
bientôt à faire une carte grise ça
m'itera de
m'énerver
[Musique]
200 km plus au nord marine et Jennifer
démarrent la journé à bord de leur bus
France service elles sont salariées du
département du Loiré et dervent 20
communes de la communauté des
Loges le véhicule à peine installé un
petit attroupement se forme déjà sur le
trottoir bonjour
bonjour
c'est une prédemande pour une carte
d'identité tout à fait oui un
renouvellement Jean-Marie vient
d'emménager sur cette commune de 8500
habitants merci je sais pas est-ce que
vous avez une adresse mail euh oui
est-ce que vous pouvez la consulter avec
vous sur votre portable ou pas du tout
ah non du tout c'est vrai qu'on a réduit
le service public bon il y a ces
systèmes de remplacement qui sont pas
négatifs et heureusement mais c'est vrai
que quand on avait notamment les impôts
moi ça n'existe plus il y a des choses
comme comme ça qu'on ne peut plus on va
plus on a plus d'interlocuteur si vous
voulez et ça c'est c'est dérangeant
bonjour bonjour allez-y rentrez le bus
peut même remplacer un guichet SNCF
essayez-vous c'est pas grandchose je
viens pour avoir des horreures de train
d'accord alors la semaine prochaine le
14 décembre j'ai pas d'ordinateur mes
enfants ils sont sont pas pas
d'internet Jennifer a été spécialement
recruté pour cet emploi pas comme les
autres
j'ai fait plein de métiers et là où je
me sens le plus à l'aise c'est le social
je c'est important pour moi d'aider les
gens de rendre service et de se sentir
utile depuis avril 2022 le bus Desloges
a déjà accompagné 3200 personnes dans
leur démarche du
quotidien l'étape de l'après-midi est un
hameau en lisière de la forêt d'Orléan
dehors une jeune femme attend je
voudrais faire un CV pour postuler un
emploi et bah j'ai pas internet chez moi
j'ai pas d'ordinateur je suis passée
devant et puis je me suis dit oh tiens
je regarder les horaires et voilà voir
si je peux faire
un après je vous aiderai pour la mise en
page si vous voulez la demande ne rentre
pas vraiment dans les attributions du
bus France service mais Marine et
Jennifer sont sensibles à la situation
de la jeune
femme qui concerne internet on peut on
peut aider donc que ça soit un CV même
si c'est pas vraiment sur internet que
c'est sur un
document après il y a des personnes qui
sont déjà venus nous voir aussi pour un
rendez-vous d'ctolip par exemple parce
que ils ont pas d'internet et qu'il y a
des des praticiens qu' qui sont que sur
Internet
asdv asdcv c'était quoi c'était une
association une association d'aide à
domicile domicile ou d'accord préciser
oui c'est important je au foyer
actuellement et j'ai besoin de
retravailler et j'ai envie de
retravailler donc bah il fallait
absolument que je le fasse soit ici soit
ailleurs mais ici c'est très bien parce
que c'est juste à côté de chez
moiz d'autres demandes ou non tout
d'accord vous m' bien
aidé le bus ferme ses portes à
17h
il y a 30 minutes de route jusqu'à
l'antenne administrative du département
où les attend Amélie la responsable du
service bon alors mesdames dites-moi
aujourd'hui comment ça s passé ça été ça
été beaucoup de monde la forê la forêt
personnes
personnes mais il arrive parois que
Marine et Jennifer ne Traun Ouss
les BU itinérants de France ne sont pas
rentabl au sens compable du mon paril
encore une fois et voilà ok c'est pas
que l'aidere dans l'immédiaté c'est
aussi motiver les personnes à ne pas
s'interrompre dans leur démarches le le
lien social et le le fait qu'elle soit
là pour leur dire mais il y a tel papier
qui manque mais vous en faites pas vous
pouvez venir demain la semaine prochaine
ou dans 15 jours on sera à tel ou tel
endroit vous en faites pas on a le temps
euh et elles ont le temps et c'est aussi
le but des Fran servic c'est de prendre
le temps si il faut prendre une heure et
quart pour une démarche elles prennent
une heure et quart ça fait partie aussi
de
mission retour dans le Berry avec Nell
et Léa qui doivent affronter les
intempéries c'est plus compliqué que
quand il fait beau mais on a pas le
choix on doit le faire donc on se pose
pas trop la
question
on passe notre notre vie un peu avec le
campingcar donc oui on bichonne on en
prend soin on est un couple
estou
ça on découvre tous les jours un nouveau
paysage on se fait remarquer tiens tu as
pas vu ça il y a un petit animal là il y
a ça et on se pose des questions voilà
qu'est-ce que c'est donc on regarde sur
internet et PU
voilàay
la ruralinette s'installe devant le
château d'argie une petite commune de
l'Indre où résident de nombreux
[Musique]
habitués monsieur dous est-ce que ça va
aller pour monter oui Michel a de gros
soucis de santé il vient régulièrement
avec sa femme et il voudrait aujourd'hui
mettre son dossier médical en ligne
c'est quoi exactement c'est votre Espace
Santé ça va permettre de mettre toutes
vos informations
médicales voilà vous savez que vous en
avez quand même pas mal donc là ben
j'attaque mon 4e cancer à chaque fois
j'ai une prise de sang donc pour
recevoir les résultats donc c'est ben
c'est
maintenant sur sur internet pour moi
c'est très compliqué parce que j'y
touche pratiquement pas pour détendre
l'atmosphère Nellie propose une
collation un moment convivial que l'on
n'attend pas forcément de la part d'une
administration on est bien accueilli ici
citron je ve bien aussi ah Monsieur le
par que moi pour mon fois voilà c'est
qu' fallait lancer le premier verre pour
Michel et sa femme la ruralinette est
une véritable bouée de secours
maintenant on fait tout par Internet on
a personne en face de nous pour discuter
que avant on on avait contact je vois
même pour les assurances pour tout on
avait contact avec la personne en face
de nous que là maintenant ça se fait
tout par internet et quand quelqu'un ne
s'y connaît pas très bien en internet on
a peut paumé merci de rien bonne journée
à vous et puis à bientôt alors et puis à
très
bientôt dans le Loiré le bus fait étape
sur un parking de supermarché à
Saint-Denis de l'hôtel michelle est la
première à grimper les
marches vous venez pourquoi alors je
viens pour avoir
une une avis d'imposition que je n'ai
pas reçu cette année d'accord et il me
le faut absolument pour le U d'accord
très bien alors on va je vais aller sur
le site des impôts je vais me connecter
sur votre espace ou et on va vous
imprimer votre invis d'imposition
d'accord d'accord et ben je vous
remercie je crois que le temps avec le
papier et le crayon c'était mieux hein
et tout le monde le
dit parce que je connais pas mal de
personnes qui sont de mon âge hein qui
disent ben hein si on avait pas les
enfants et ben on est dans le caca comme
on dit alors
jeà et ben écoutez je vous remercie
infiniment bonjour madame monur bONJ
bonjour monsieur c'est le tour de
Patricia et Lionel qui souhaitaent faire
un changement d'adresse sur leur carte
grise je pensais avoir fait ma mon
changement d'adresse sur Internet sur un
bon site et en fin de compte B le site
Ctait un site bidon et comme il depuis 3
mois j'ai fait ça il y a 3 mois j'ai
toujours rien reçu de alors je me suis
dit il y a un problème donc c'est pour
ça je suis ven voir ces dames et vous
avez payé oui oui 30 € 30 € vous êtes
pas les seuls quand comp tape par
exemple ans sur sur Internet faut faire
attention c'est marqué sponsorisé et en
fait ce sont pas les vrais sites
internet il faut descendre un peu plus
bas et vous allez voir qu'il y a le site
officiel mais ça si on le sait pas même
moi je me suis fait avoir et pourtant
j'ai 36 ans et internet c'est l'air de
nos jours donc rassurez-vous c'est pas
que vous la fracture numérique concerne
surtout les personnes
et les plus modestes mais elle touche
aussi certains jeunes fort de ce constat
de nombreuses communes demandent le
passage du bus France service au Centre
d'Action communale et sociale de
Saint-Denis de l'hôtel où stationne
aujourd'hui le bus margeoline lavoisie
observe depuis longtemps la situation se
dégradé la
dématérialisation cache la misère
sociale derrière un écran et un clavier
et ça c'est dangereux je pense que
l'État n'a pas compris
l'ampleur de ce qui allait se passer on
se rend compte aujourd'hui qu'on met à
mal plein de
personnes et que à mon sens ça crée un
handicap supplémentaire et il y a une
problématique qui se détache c'est qu'il
y a des gens qui baissent les bras qui
abandonnent et qui n'ont plus accès à
des droits élémentaires en
fait dans une société de plus en plus
numérisée c'est désormais à l'administré
de remplir lui-même ses dossiers une
économie pour les pouvoirs publics mais
à quel prix pour les plus fragiles